[Música]
la verdad es que estoy muy honrado de
estar frente a ustedes
pero debo serles honesto francamente
esto es intimidante
intimidante porque a pesar de ser hombre
que nosotros somos gente segura nosotros
somos dueños de la palabra me siento
como probablemente muchas mujeres se
sienten en su vida cotidiana aterrado
aterrado tratando de tener un mínimo de
consideración si hoy he venido un poco a
provocarlos a provocar las y hablar de
micro machismo
como una forma de violencia
pero no una forma de violencia física es
algo que vemos todos los días muchas
veces al día
pero pasa inadvertida es casi invisible
pero creo que necesito contarles un poco
hacia atrás yo vengo de una familia
donde
era totalmente matriarcal mi abuela era
la que dirigía el rumbo de la familia
ella y sus hijas que eran guerreras
permanentes
mi madre entre ellas eran las que
definían el futuro de todos en ese
contexto era imposible pensar el
machismo en realidad la verdad es que
todas y todos éramos feministas por
defecto
recuerdo cuando era chico el que nos
preparaba el desayuno pero al colegio
era mi padre el que iba al mercado era
él y eso era algo normal no era algo
especial
pues llegamos a mi casa y en mi casa
seguimos la herencia y seguimos la
tradición
y tengo 33 mujeres luchadoras y
valientes
mi hija luciana la menor fernanda y mi
esposa más es la que probablemente es la
más feminista de la casa
y bueno las cosas siguen igual con mi
hijo rodrigo vamos al mercado cocinamos
y no solo el cocinero chef fácil de fin
de semana que hacen la comida y deja
todo tirado sino que lavamos la soya de
los platos etcétera etcétera
en ese contexto
se imaginarán que para mí
y en el mundo en que vivimos decíamos
somos gente normal pero hace unos meses
me pasó algo bastante extraño y que es
el origen de esta charla mía que estudie
en europa vino de vacaciones
y nos comenta que su novio iba a venir y
que se iba a quedar en casa
yo fui tan incauto en mi onda de
estructurar y ordenar como un buen
anfitrión que pregunte y donde va a
dormir
y tuvo una respuesta contundente
mi hija menor y mi esposa me dijeron con
la luz obvio
y yo me sentí como un niño regañado y
conteste obvio muy despacito
y después me quedé pensando y decía que
hubiese pasado si esto era el revés si
llegaba mi hijo con la novia yo
seguramente ni siquiera me hubiera
puesto a pensar dónde dormir yo la novia
porque era obvio que tenía que dormir
con él
y ahí hice como un pequeño clic eligen o
algo algo anda mal acá y le empecé a dar
vueltas y bueno gracias dios tenemos
internet entre el internet y me encontré
con la palabra micromachismo y dije no
esto es imposible pero soy un tipo
normal yo no soy machista entonces no
vale bueno en esa búsqueda me encontré
con la definición de un señor que se
llama luis bonino que en realidad es el
que acuña la palabra al principio de los
90 nunca lo había escuchado y según yo
soy un tipo que más o menos lee pero
jamás había escuchado la definición y me
voy a tomarla
licencia de leer esto porque me pareció
bastante interesante dice este término
designa a las sutiles e imperceptibles
maniobras y estrategias de ejercicio de
poder de dominio masculino en lo
cotidiano
que atentan en diversos grados contra la
autonomía femenina avilés artes trucos
tretas y manipulaciones con la que los
varones intentan imponer a las mujeres
sus propias razones deseos e intereses
en la vida cotidiana
y esto además es consciente e
inconsciente wow
siguiente página que me tira el internet
y veo una tienda de ropa muy conocida
con ropa para bebé hermosas chiquititas
cosas bellísimas para los que han tenido
hijos son maravillosas y encuentro una
camiseta celeste que dice inteligente
como papá de tierna y al lado estaba la
rosadita que decía linda como mamá
no podría ser al revés
podría ser lindo como papá y inteligente
como mamás no bueno se me dieron
millones de esas camisetas y allí empecé
a pensar en los ejemplos cotidianos y un
poco a cuestionarme si realmente esto es
así
primero se me vino a la cabeza el típico
ejemplo de la mamá de unos mis mejores
amigos que decía no yo le plancha las
camisas porque el nene no sabe planchar
las ok nunca aprendió él nunca aprenderá
una cosa que me pasó en una oficina
donde una chica le decía a un compañero
de trabajo que no entre donde el jefe
porque estaba en actitud de minitas
me imagino que es curioso sensible que
habrá pasado no tengo idea
y de ahí empecé a buscar temas netamente
laborales entonces vemos un típico
directorio corporativo donde la
presencia femenina siempre es reducida
y cuando una mujer toma la palabra
cualquiera de los hombres que están allí
sea más o menos con mayor la va a
interrumpir y no va a importarle lo que
esté diciendo y no importa si lo dice
bien o lo dice mal
pero no solo la corta sino que en muchos
casos ha pasado que oye tú tienes buena
letra no porque no toma los apuntes
yo creo que es lo más denigrante que
haya una reunión bueno pero pasa
y así me vinieron a la mente un montón
de ejemplos y cosas que he vivido una
empresa donde la mayoría de las mujeres
de los colaboradores las empresas son
mujeres decían es mejor tener jefe
hombre porque así hay como equilibrio
guau
y de ahí pensaba en los roles y hay
roles que automáticamente los definimos
para los hombres o para las mujeres
alguna vez han visto un recepcionista o
ustedes contrataría en un niñera bueno
los roles parece que están
preestablecidos no es cierto el cuidado
desde las mujeres etcétera etcétera y
ahí hay que empezar a darle una vuelta
si uno se pone a pensar en estos
ejemplos seguramente la lista será
interminable y ustedes van a ir pensando
en todas las cosas que les pasan
diariamente
le voy a decir algo
y creo que se ha notado los hombres
tenemos miedo nos encanta el statu quo y
para mantener ese statu quo una de las
grandes herramientas que he encontrado
es el micro machismo
si es una forma de violencia
en algún momento la denominaron
violencia suave
tras violencia al fin
y lo crítico de este tipo de violencia
es que es socialmente aceptada
y que la vivimos todos los días
yo les propongo
que cuando nos topemos con este tipo de
actitudes pongamos la en evidencia
hagamos el ejercicio nosotros
sin hacerlo público- en principio se van
a sorprender yo estoy haciendo este
ejercicio y realmente me ha llamado la
atención la cantidad de veces que me
pasen un día en distinto los círculos
sociales en distintas actividades y es
permanente
y el problema más profundo aún es que
esto pega acá
a las mujeres les pega en la psiquis
ah
yo creo realmente que
los cambios se hacen con pequeñas cosas
con actitudes con mostrar contra el
ejemplo yo creo que la equidad es un
tema de reciprocidad
y creo que juntos
deberíamos tratar de cambiar esto poco a
poco dando el ejemplo
y lo digo así porque creo que nos lo
debemos pero que en realidad nos lo
merecemos
gracias
[Aplausos]